good evening I am fine Sasha the
director of the Columbia Paracel Islands
program and on behalf of the Alliance
Program and the Columbia School of
International and public affairs it's a
real pleasure for me to welcome you all
tonight at Columbia for a unique panel
discussion on freedom of expression the
concept of freedom of expression
deserved informed debate to go beyond
the linear or dichotomous activities it
is too often portrayed and tonight we
are extremely fortunate to have with us
five distinguished guests who will share
with us their views on the very
definition of freedom of expression
across continents across history and the
real exchange on the cultural the
religious the political the
philosophical the legal underpinnings of
a freedom of expression and of course
freedom of expression is widely taught
at columbia university across campus and
is of great interest to our students on
campus and of course our great interest
to our faculty as well and i'd like to
thank some of them tonight without whom
this gunner gathering would not have
been a possible so I'd like to thank my
colleagues and the faculty at the Center
for Democracy toleration and religion
the Institute for religion culture and
public life the Middle East Institute
the European Institute the mezzo Francis
the European the Gulf three Center and
the intentional media advocacy and
communication specialization at Siple
and overall I'd like to extend my
warmest thank tonight to either lika the
International League against racism and
anti-semitism who
has been co-sponsoring this event with
us tonight all of you know the ricotta
till I will say it is a major human
rights NGO accredited to the United
Nations and in particular tonight I
would like to thank you very much the
president of the liquor in the u.s.
madam Martina Rubenstein without without
whom the the panel we're going to hear
from tonight would not have been
possible to thank you too to Martin and
totally calm and so now on behalf of the
Columbia Committee it's a great honor
for me to welcome our guests tonight so
welcome to Colombia mr. Belinelli levy
Bernama we divvy the French philosopher
and author the author of america
american vertical most of you have a red
I'm sure and who's the voice actions and
writings have Cape kept raising the very
fine question of what it means to stand
for democratic standards in a global
Iran we also have with us professor
peter on peter is actually a great
friend of the Alliance Program I
delighted to have him with us tonight
Peter on is the dean of the school of
general studies at Columbia University
Peter on is a director of the Middle
East Institute at Columbia University
and Peter on is a professor of religion
a great specialist of Islamic religion
and comprehend comparative religion we
also have with us university professor
planter greenawalt whose seminal work on
free speech and the First Amendment has
paved the way for American academia and
will present for us tonight the American
position on our topic and we have with
us as well Philip Schmidt a lawyer based
in Paris and a Columbia alumnus as well
for that matter from the law school
Philip Schmidt is the vice president of
the league
and he is also the president of the elac
the international network against cyber
hate and last but not least please let
me welcome to Colombia our moderator
tonight widely admired and praised the
editor of The New Yorker mr. David
Remnick who will moderate a panel
discussion tonight so we'll start right
away with a panel discussion among our
panelists that could be moderated by
David Remnick we will then open the
floor for Q&A session with the audience
it's a great tradition at Columbia that
we want to keep that is to say exchange
with the audience there is a mic in the
central Alice or for those of you who
don't know you will you will be invited
to stand up in line and we'll take three
questions at a time for our panelists
and then we'll end our session with
concluding remarks by Donovan V DV
Jurgis thank you again we're extremely
grateful to have you all with us tonight
I have to say that your presence truly
embodies what we are the Alliance
Program tried to do semester after
semester and on a daily basis that is to
say attempt to offer a platform for
transatlantic debate a platform for
dialogue on the pressing issues of our
times always rooted in the academia
thank you and enjoy a debate
good evening I'm David Remnick and I i
should say i'll be very very brief that
as an editor I get invited every once in
a while to a First Amendment discussion
with our national or international or
local at the journalism school or
university or here there and it's with
this with a dose of some guilt why why
some guilt because one recognizes one's
preposterous good fortune and I just to
tell you a personal story I had never
been an editor of anything other than my
high school newspaper before beginning
as the editor of The New Yorker whatever
preposterous calculation went into that
decision I leave to somebody else I I
will tell you my experience of being an
editor and what the First Amendment
meant my and my very rapid discovery is
after a couple of months of loosely
defined editing the New Yorker we had a
story by a journalist you probably know
named Seymour Hersh yeah this is 1998
and psy wrote a story in which he
accused almost every but everybody of
almost everything including the idea
that the Prime Minister of Russia had
taken bribes from Saddam Hussein and and
other various crimes and misdemeanors I
had been at the washington post as a boy
and the only thing I knew was it Ben
Bradlee than the great editor of The
Washington Post would call Katherine
Graham a proprietor of the Washington
Post and say I just wanted to let you
know we're going to publish I don't know
Watergate tomorrow it was called the no
surprises rule so I called my proprietor
sign new house who owns the magazine
lock stock and barrel and I said we're
going to publish this story accusing
almost everybody I'm almost everything
next week but don't worry it's been
checked on to a fare-thee-well and
lawyers have read it and
I have great confidence and I even know
all the sources that the reader may not
know and there was a long pause at the
end of the telephone and sign new house
said that sounds very interesting that
was it that was the last time I ever
called him about any story about
anything whether it was Abu Ghraib or
anything of the kind and there may be
limitations on what we do and there may
be ideological arguments about what we
do but in terms of the issues that we're
going to discuss tonight we are
extraordinarily with people on this
panel are extraordinarily as you are
fortunate to be in the situation we are
in not everyone is tonight we're going
to begin with a format in which
everybody on the panel will have will
begin with a five minute introductory
statement argument sense of situation in
their field then we will get into a
discussion which I'll lead for a while
and then you will ask some questions not
statements not not speeches but ask
questions of anyone you choose and then
at the end of Bernard kwaito the style
of the closing Aria and any good opera
will give a closing statement and I want
to thank you in advance for your
patience and cooperation and I hope your
rigorous participation when it comes
your turn will begin with Bernard
honoree levy
yeah thank you David Remnick thank you
very much first I first of all I would
like to apologize in front of the 180
people I think who have been left
outside and hua condemn to see us
through a screen the audience was the
whole was not big enough to receive
everybody and we are I know that David
Remnick shares my I apologize we are so
sorry for that in five minutes to tell
you my feeling is of course very
difficult I would just like to put the
following point we are received here we
are speaking under the behalf of an
organization a French one which is
called a leak how the president of it
but we go bear being here on the first
rank and which is increasing in
principle devoted to prevent condemn
some sort of speeches we must not hide
ourselves behind our finger it is a fact
that the lucra has been created in order
to to prevent to censor some sort of
speeches some sort of world of worlds
appeal to cream to crime number one
opinion crime advocacy of crime Lehigh's
done to stop that under penalty of law
in order to advocacy for this sort of
crime which is anti-semitism and racism
Lika has been founded upon the idea that
anti-semitism and racism are not ideas
are not opinions but our criminal acts
and should be condemned as such and
likh ha I think as all sort of
anti-defamation league's in the world
believe also that you can have some
worlds some speeches who are able to
commit crimes on huge scale I would take
only one example the genocide in Rwanda
genocide in Rwanda in 1994 which needed
LeGrande nor any body and even the time
to stop was really genocide committed by
words it was not only accompanied by
words it was not only with world's I
with additional world works was really
the weapon by which the crime was
committed so we know in France you know
in a miracle league hard-nosed better
than anybody else it is its founding
stone that words can be criminal and
that as a French poet stéphane mallarmé
said at the time of the trial of
Annunaki guy called Felix fennel Felix
Fenian beginning end of the 19th century
world's can be bombs words can be the
most efficient of the bombs so no ang
ilysm know they my god G this is a part
of the problem these being said what is
true and what motivator that was our
gathering of today is that there is
today in America in Europe all over the
world a new trend trying to censor the
speech to trying to censor the free
speaking on behalf not
of preventing crime but under the
pretext of respecting paying respect
paying homage to some communities we
have a new topic today which is by
respect of some communities some world
should be forbidden and Samsung this is
the topic of today not the sort of
worlds which help to commit and did
commit genocide in Rwanda and could
commit now genocide in Bondi but these
sort of worlds which are supposed to
attack to indicate to blaspheme a
community or a religion especially in
the field of Islamism this is a new not
only but especially on this we I give
you very quickly my personal reply which
I submit according to the tradition of
this place to the discussion of the
audience and of my fellow partners my
reply is the following two points or
three points point number one for any
community and especially and therefore
for this community of communities which
is a nation which is a people nation
freedom of speech is the first of all
the freedoms if you take away if you
retire if you if you withdraw the
freedom of speech it is as if you
withdraw the main brick which makes the
whole castle the whole house consistent
so our Muslim our Islam our Muslim
friends who say for instance that some
sort
speeches some sort of cartoons should be
forbidden in the name of the respect of
his lomb must know that if we take away
this freedom all the other freedoms will
fall apart this is what bahama constant
said this is the theory of alex e de
tocqueville and i know that you have in
this country many thinkers who may know
much less than all of you who would say
the same so can't reply which I deliver
to the audience and I submit to
discussion there is a sort of trick
there is a sort of to the pass pass
there is a sort of operation of
contraband how do you see contraband
smuggled there is a smuggling operation
these sort of people tell us we defined
respect of our community in realities
they say something else they defend some
values which have nothing to do with
democracy with respect of the community
and so on especially in the field of
Islam you have to their real fight
inside Islam between democratic forces
and in degrees fundamentalist all
fascist forces when you preach the
limitation of freedom of speech you give
your favor to you give your preference
to you give help to the integrase
fundamentalist and fascist wings
tendencies inside Islam we must know
that the one begins with the so-called
respect of the values of Islam in really
take the real deal the real undercurrent
smuggling is provide for the denial of
the face of the women the possibility of
killing of somebody who
and religion the apostasy and so on and
this is not vicious number two and
number three what I personally think is
that the real respect of a community the
real respect of a religion whatever it
is consists precisely in showing that
she is a ball or it is able to stand to
receive them without being broken
without falling into a pit into pieces
these sorts of attacks the right of
blasphemy blasphemy you say the right of
blasphemy is the right for the
freethinkers of course but it is also
right which I do think we when it is
implemented not weekends but reinforce
reinforce proves the solidity and the
consistency of the religion or the
community which is concerned a religion
which is not able to stand to do with
blasphemy religion which would feel not
only wounded but killed but strikin to
death by your blasphemy is really a
religion which is already dead so what I
mean is that even in in the interest of
those of these sort of communities even
if you take the point of view of those
who with great with real faith with real
my soul and mind are attached to their
values right to blasphemy is essential
also for them Christianity would have
been dead since long without Voltaire
and without other free thinkers who have
implemented blasphemy help the Christian
thinkers to resist blasphemy to build
some to develop some antidotes to
develop some forces of resistance to
that and it will be the same for Islam
so for the sake of democracy for the
sake of anti-fascism and for the sake of
these religions of communities of today
who pretend to be wounded by free speech
we have to defend free speech more than
ever today thank you Peter
let me take a slightly different tag as
professor of Islamic love to be able to
argue Islam is so unique it's totally
different from everything else in fact
it as conventional as any other
religious tradition religious traditions
espouse truth claims the argument is
that if you embrace that truth claim
that truth to be embodied in the way you
live the dilemma comes when religious
communities become either partially or
fully engaged with the apparatus of the
state and are able therefore to impose a
vision of homogeneity on their society
Christian society did this for centuries
the blasphemy laws in the UK were
abolished in the 1990s hmm now i might
say how terrible the Brits were no it
harks back to the tradition when
Christianity was the ideological
underpinning of many European societies
so the issue isn't embedded within a
particular religious tradition it's the
extent to which a society engages this
effort on the part of religious
communities to argue for their truth
claims and that their vision ought to be
embraced or imposed on everyone else and
how the rest of society reacts against
it quite interestingly in contrast to
the European experience I assure you you
do not find many American Muslims
screaming that they're being offended in
the United States why because to be an
American is to be offended
any religious community that doesn't
learn how to navigate the criticisms the
blasphemies that occur on a daily basis
be you Jewish bu Christian bu
evangelical bu Muslim be or secularist
is not engaged fully in the structures
of American society in a sense it works
here because everyone's in the same boat
and the ability of Muslims to adapt in
the United States as immigrants in fact
they've adapted more quickly more
effectively than almost any other
immigrant community in the history of
this country so it is not Islam that
represents some kind of threat to
democracy but it is true that immigrants
coming from homogeneous environments
where in fact religious ideals were
enshrined in the structures of the state
do have difficulty engaging societies in
which freedom of speech is cherished and
you better be ready to take your lumps
to end I would also say that societies
that haven't done quite as well as one
would like in coping with the influx of
immigrant populations tend to have more
of these ideological conflicts
underneath which are frequently very
important social and political conflicts
that are far more important i would say
necessarily than arguments over a burka
or whether you wear a headscarf to
school however let me end by saying the
construction of secularism is not the
same as you move from the United States
to Europe in class I could care less
whether you're bananas on your
it is irrelevant the dress code in an
American classroom but Americans are
horrified at the thought of supporting
religious schools with tactile tax
dollars Lacey day in France is focused
on the school system on ensuring that
everyone becomes a French citizen in
that context so no you can't wear a
yarmulke you will can't wear across you
can't wear a headscarf but they will go
ahead and support religious schools
because they want religious schools to
be of the quality of the public school
system it's a totally different
construction of secularism I'm not
arguing one's better or one is worse but
they're different and it's in that
context that one has to understand the
function of religious ideology and the
secular state thank you can't Greenwald
thanks so I'm going to take my five
minutes to try to sort of sketch the
legal within constitutional situation
not during the United States the legal
status is mainly controlled by our first
amendment which says Congress shall make
no law respecting an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press now
originally that applied only against the
federal government and it's made up of
cool against the states by the 14th
amendment passed after the civil war in
our early history states had laws
against blasphemy casting aspersions on
or denying Christian truths of the only
glass me that was wrong was against
Christianity and also against profanity
and this was true even in state that had
no establishment
and provisions now such laws would be
regarded as violations of the
Establishment Clause and the free speech
clause and if they these assertions were
made as part of somebody's religious
convictions contrary to what they were
blaspheming would be protected by free
exercise as well so what are the ground
rules for one speech can be punished
well if you directly solicit somebody
else to commit a crime that can be
punished but if you incite to criminal
violence more generally like kill all
the Jews something along those lines
that can be punished only if the
advocacy is directed to or incite a to
inciting or producing imminent lawless
action imminent lawless action and it's
likely to incite or produce such action
so that's very limiting even in terms of
advocacy of illegal or criminal action
now this leaves us with the categories
of what we might loosely call hate
speech or fighting words and this would
be reached by breach of the peace
statutes or harassment statutes that
were forbidden DS so this is language
that's deeply offensive to the audience
and we can imagine that forms of
blasphemy could constitute an extreme
denigration of a group of believers or
individuals and we do know that some
forms have produced violent reaction so
what could there be a basis for
prohibition here well fighting words
have been conceived as in face-to-face
encounters encounters and the comments
are protected unless they produce a
violent response in the average
addressee now there are nuances about
people who could the average addresses
be what percentages violent responses we
need to think there'd be and some notion
of equality of audiences and and sort of
basic ideas but I'm going to pass over
all
all of those so one problem is that you
might produce somebody that fighting but
that's very limited hate speech can be
wounding to listeners and I think we
have to be aware of that thinking about
these general problems that something
that is directed at an individual that's
very offensive and abusive can be quite
wounding and that's especially true if
the comments are actually aimed as they
sometimes are at humiliating somebody
and sometimes people are sought out just
if just to humiliate them so probably in
theory that could be protected but it's
so hard to decide what somebody's motive
is when you engage in this kind of
action the speech can be deeply
offensive in some situations to a
broader audience again can you please
talk into the mic some people came
forward yeah I'm sorry so and they're
also a question of long-term harms that
perpetuating negative stereotypes
silencing people in a minority or
oppressed group and we can think of
sexist and racist speech along these
lines and forms of blasphemy could be
used in this kind of way so I think we
could imagine situations in which would
be a kind of hate speech that could
conceivably be punished but that's a
very narrow category there would be more
latitude in campus speech codes although
I think what has to be very careful
about those and in work place harassment
discrimination on the basis of religion
is a form of workplace harassment and we
might imagine that blasphemy about
somebody's religion directed at them
could be a form of harassment but in
general if publications are deeply
offensive on religious grounds the basic
rule in the United States is that people
have to tolerate that and that on
balance this is desirable as an aspect
of religious freedom and freedom of
speech the United States is more
protective than virtually any other
country and I think that in an overall
evaluation of whether that's desirable
or not one has to think a bit about
history and culture but in general I
think the idea of a lot of protection
for speech is on balance and good
idea okay thank you Felix me great can't
i'm going to fill up on you because you
just explained the legislation in the US
and i'm very happy but after hearing
can't you understand that it's not true
to say it's not correct to say that
there's no limit in the u.s. to freedom
of speech there is always a limit and
the controversies where is the limit
that's the controversy that the
controversy very interesting and in fact
the views in the US are very different
from the you from reviews in other
Western countries Western democracies so
not completely different countries and
the lawyers were professors with fingers
we politicians are not able to discuss
and to go for world together on what is
the limit the problem is today we need
to have a common limit and why do we
need to have a common limit it's because
of the Internet freedom of expression
today will occur mainly on the Internet
that's where everybody you everybody can
speak and can send a message all over
the world and if you have a legislation
in one country it will not apply if
someone can go in another country and of
course send messages open a website sand
be a member of Facebook or whatever so
we need windy today to have a common
approach and i think i would like today
to be also a beginning of a common
approach because up to today when you
have people again lawyers whatever
speaking together on those kind of issue
we cannot understand each other i'm in a
not only me but in a different position
because both educated in Europe and in
the US are like in the middle of the
Atlantic and I can feel and understand
both values because you said that why we
have different legislation on free
speech denial of a low-cost all those
issues is it's because of our past but
today the future means that we have we
have to find a common approach we have
to find a common devastation it's really
I think today we we internet for me the
main topic because visuals the First
Amendment is it a good answer do you
think that indeed in fact the incitement
to violence should be the only limit or
as we think in Europe in Australia in
Canada so very close to here you cannot
you have also to respect the dignity of
the person and of course now comes in
the whole the issue regarding with
defamation of religion on this issue we
are very clear we protect human beings
we do know we do not protect ideas in no
way and I just want to tell you that yes
we're as a trend at the United Nation
human right concealer to try to have
defamation of religion we did pass 3
resolution in five years but you have to
also that in Ireland in Ireland so
member of a European Union we just pass
a blasphemy law so we think that it will
not be legal because of European
legislation but for the time being
you've got a new legislation very simply
in Ireland and it's not beyond European
country so yes you see we go from the
First Amendment to defamation of
religion in the middle you've got
countries like France and other European
countries and now if we want to have a
common ground we we need to find a
common legislation that's really my
apart philippe maybe i'll begin with
philippe i'm not quite sure what you're
suggesting we've just been witness to an
international meeting in Copenhagen
where what was at stake was quite
potentially an ecological catastrophe
that could swamp us all and we left with
an agreement so slight so dissolute as
to beggar the imagination what we've had
a description of here is the vast
differences of we of whether blasphemy
is even good or bad how do you suggest
monitoring the internet legislating the
internet when the culture is involved
whether it's even if difference between
the French and the United States much
less Saudi Arabia and France or or Yemen
know how do you what is what do you have
in mind as the realm of the possible or
even the realm of the good and the
desirable yeah I mean the first of all I
mean regarding VI environment at least
the very beginning of
the country's speaking together and
obviously you're right it will be a long
time just have a speech from malaria
Clinton it will be a long long time to
arrive to something that will be agreed
by all the countries however we can
start we can start the United States and
the other Western countries I mean for
instance when you fight cyber hate in
Europe our main problem is not Saudi
Arabia it's because you know if someone
wants to to establish itself isn't it is
not going to Saudi Arabia it's been a
minute give us examples of what cyber
hate are and and and what their dangers
are and why they should be acted upon
okay so for instance if you have and
again we are not tonight going to decide
whether or not denial of viola cost
should be authorized when I say we are
not going to discuss of course we can I
don't want to I'm for free speech but
you've got many countries where denial
of viola cost is forbidden period okay
you've got democratic countries Germany
Austria Australia Canada mini and if you
want to if you have someone who is
having the website for instance with
denial of other coastal materials if
this person is in false you cannot you
can go after it you go after this person
so what is going to do this person is
going to establish in the US and thanks
to the First Amendment or because of a
First Amendment it will not be able we
will not be able to preserve his person
can I hear from this side of the panel
whether legislation against the denial
of the Holocaust is necessarily
either a priority or good or an extend
it to any either conspiracy thinking or
preposterous historical theory as you
know it's a difficult question this
question of denial of follow I mean of
condemning and putting a low against
denial of Holocaust and denier of other
genocides not only Oracle's on one side
one could say and I have a lot of
friends who say it is so stupid to deny
all costs and the truth is so strong the
evidence is so clear that we should let
the good currency get rid of the bad
currency why make low this is an
acceptable argument we could think like
that on the other side the reason why as
for myself after having thought at
length on this question for years I
finally decided that the law was good is
the following I will say I'm sorry very
shortly in few words but it's suppose it
could be developed for me the denial of
the genocide is part of the genocide
itself it is part of the genocide it is
very clear in the genocide against Jews
as you know the structure of the
genocide supposed had embedded into
itself the fact of the denial the SS
Himmler and so on said not only we will
kill them but we are going to erase the
trace of the killing the denial is part
of the crime same for the Armenians the
committal the executioner's of the low
cost of the Armenians said exactly the
same it
is not enough to kill we have to at the
same time in the same movement in the
same breathing we have to commit and
erase the crime so there is a very
peculiar structure of genocide it is not
a crime as another one there is a
peculiar structure which having the
denial integrated in the crime makes the
possibility and imposes I think the
necessity of finishing the denial which
is part of the crime I'd like Kent and
peter also to address this so I think
there is an argument about whether it
should be not allowed in European
countries but I your reasons struck me
as quite implausible for the following
reason assuming that the part of the
idea of genocide or that particular
genocide was that it was also going to
be covered up that was part of what it
was but now we're generations later and
the question is should people be able to
deny that that existed or not it to me
it wouldn't make any difference suppose
there a basic idea have been let's
publicize that to everybody and you know
that it's great we're doing this and as
if we're the same few generations later
and some people are denying their took
place so I don't see the connection
between the denial or whether it took
place generations later and what the
underlying philosophy was at the
genocide in the first place that seems
to be to be a pretty remote relation
very briefly up I don't want to
legislate against stupidity that I want
to see it out in front and it usually is
an indicator or something far more
pernicious and if in fact that stupidity
represents a deeply ingrained evil and
hate I want it out in public so it can
be dealt with and debated you legislate
against it
recurs the problem it pushes it
underground I can't rapidity it is not
stupidity look even genocide of home
onda it's very interesting and it's
really something which is peculiar to
genocides which is part of genocide even
in order a few years after a few month
after maybe at the very moment you had
already people practicing the denial you
are not denial of anything nobody denies
that we work in the is in the United
States nobody denies today that the
earth is
wrong and so on there is a very specific
manya concerning genocide and genocide
only including maybe Cambodian da who it
is really part of the scheme it is
really part of the enterprise so it is
really part of the crime it is not only
stability not only a fantasy we have to
think metaphysically the link between
the denial and the crime this is a real
point on I Drive in fact low or not low
this is where not if I walk into a even
even a hotel bookstore in Cairo I can
buy copies of the protocols of the
Elders of Zion when I lived in
Washington DC and I walked into a
left-wing bookstore I forget what it was
i could buy copies of lenin and stalin
where does the legislating stop isn't
isn't the question have to do with
social context we're buying a copy of
stalin in the united states and 1989 is
fairly harmless and actually an academic
endeavor whereas quite possibly buying
the other book in the other place has
another repercussions where does the
legislating stop and and not and I like
that I by the way I'm fully aware of the
skittish structure of this discussion
which you will bring down to earth and
your own questions in a while
I'm not in favor of censoring anything
stallion of course not lending even less
and even protocol even protocol of the
elders of zion i'm not in favor of
censoring there is a debate in France
about we failed in OC dinner we felt in
Oh Celine you have a two-fold the world
this excuse me the novels of and now
notebooks of saline who wrote journey to
the end of the night and whose
anti-semitism runs even more deeply than
we even knew before until these until
these things were published just exactly
it's a good piece in the new york review
of books about your you have you have
huge novels of saline which belongs to
the best of literature of the 20th
century and you have three books
bagatelle pumasok equal de cada Allah
Buddha brecon which are disgusting
anti-semitic books there is a debate in
France on the question to know if they
have to be some sort or not they are
censored I'm against I think they should
not be sand so people should make their
own opinion about that no doubt the
protocol of the Elders of Zion is so
stupid is so crazy these are I agree
they should be they should be allowed
they should be allowed in the Arab
country the problem is not to to censor
protocol of elders a and it is to to put
the question of the fascism in Arab
countries which has never been really
raised this question it is much further
than the book protocol there is real
participation of the Arab world as in
Europe to the fascism and this question
has never been uncovered so the question
today is not to censor it is to earn
sensor in the Arab country the work to
do is not just to put censorship on this
book or that it is the contrary to to
suppress the censorship on the big on a
huge piece of the collective memory
which is the fascist part of the Arab
memory you have in Egypt you haven't
draw that you have in Iraq you have in
Syria a big bunch of the local memory
which is as compromised with fascism as
France as Italy as hamaya assume Gary
and so on the question has been raised
the morning has been done or during the
morning the solo in the morning in
Germany in France it was not so easy to
the hard work very painful some families
have been broken some lives and some
reputation have been destroyed but it
has been done all over the world except
in these countries where you can find
the protocol of a dollar so the question
is not to censor the contrary it is to
to to open Peter we may we speak of the
Arab world maybe you could speak of the
diversity if there if you like of the
state of play of these questions there I
would agree with bell now that you find
a number of Islamic societies and a
number of Arab societies that really are
totalitarian and in which discourse is
controlled and there is a kind of
political ideology that really is
imposed and taught in the schools etc
etc it's completely unhealthy it stifles
really the educated elites who do try to
move beyond the limitations added that
the Religious Right is a horribly
threatening environment both within
Islamic societies as well as outside but
it isn't because of Islam it's because
of the state of these various societies
in terms of economics politics and their
relationships with the State of Israel
that that has been the
catalyst for really this cliche and
deeply embedded frequently anti-semitic
view of Jews and Israeli society now I
think again with in Israeli society
you're not going to find the happiest
depictions of Islam and or Arabs but I
think again that has a lot to do with
the political issues and social issues
not fundamentally related here's Peter
some years ago now what year was his
cover being assassinated mid 90s right
it was the question came up whether the
actual campaign in which bibi netanyahu
was taking place there was a lot of talk
loose talk and political talk that
because Robyn was negotiating with and
coming to agreements with the
Palestinians that he was deserving of
violence that that that according to law
as interpreted Jewish law as interpreted
by some of these people that any time
you give away any part of Jewish Jewish
lands I'll spare you the scare quotes
whether it's the west bank or Gaza or
any and any other portion of Israeli
either occupied or is really land that
it was legitimate to visit violence upon
that politician there was a lot of loose
talk some of it implicitly in the
opinion of some encouraged by major
political candidates including Netanyahu
we know what happened a a fanatic shot
and killed his Robin should that
kind of speech whether it was in you she
vote or in the street or in political
speech bin band and legislated against
you wanted to take that technically yet
again and we free speech because we are
human rights lawyers it means
of course and I want to say it again we
are for free speech but when we are when
we have to put the limit and as a matter
of fact we human right Universal
Declaration on human rights itself says
there has to be a free speech it's a
principle but just after universal
declaration says valid for him it and
that's your question and again we go
back to what is very good to the
question in the case of Robin I mean we
remember very well that indeed there was
direct incitement to violence so yes in
this case I think even and with the
First Amendment we could have prosecuted
per person we're inciting people to
violent and that's something with very
interesting if I may you would have put
a lot of people in jail at that I mean I
sec yeah and again the fact is and it
goes again to what happened in in Rwanda
and we've internet now you've got
incitement to hatred that destroy life
and yes in this case you need to protect
the life of those person and you've got
also something that you know better in
the US when in in France for instance
cyberbullying you know cyber building
the fact is that you've got now kids and
we are going to be Alice for the
internet and i did a conference at the
UN like six months ago and we heard and
i'm sure you know this story of this
young person 14 years old and he was
ours by
by v / student for the internet and his
pants were not in a position to see that
because it was on his computer so at
school ii was i was he went back to whom
he was a vast always have us and again
it wasn't direct incitement to violence
but yes we destroy his life and as a
matter fact he committed suicide so and
that's something with the internet that
comes and comes and again i mean i love
the internet it's amazing but yes when
we need to put some limits we have to
and yes in the case of having obviously
some of the people could have been Jalen
and who knows I mean perhaps could have
changed the life of revenant of the
region I think Ken wanted to say
something on this question of internet
legislation on this I we do have a lot
against threatening the life of the
President so that's sort of special but
I think picking up on your point about
this thing it's so hard to know when the
discussion is serious people talked
about killing Obama during the campaign
and so on and it's it's very difficult I
just wanted to mention on the internet
thing it's not just the United States
government negotiating something that
might be some kind of compromise with
the other countries but this you know
suppose you agreed on something the
Supreme Court might come along and say
no that violates the First Amendment you
can change for fifth amendment
I think that will only apply if you're a
corporation as far as I can tell in the
corporation with eyes yeah that's really
because if I just wanna remark I mean
it's very important the First Amendment
to apply only to the government so when
you have companies like Facebook saying
okay we don't want to to stop for
instance denial of your locus material
it's wrong I mean we can do it it's just
their policy if we want to do it we can
do it nobody can prevent them from doing
it okay let's have that first awkward
question from the from the from the
group and I think you line up at that
microphone would be the great thing and
please I beg of you no speeches
questions and please direct them to
somebody on the panel yes a good evening
this cuts really want to introduce
yourself now hold on to yes I'm mr. cam
and i'm here for harry edition of others
and myself okay recent goes to the blast
the blasphemy issue recently the Pope
encouraged Samar's bishop I think in
Maryland to condemn representative
Kennedy for not voting against abortion
rights and considering it as he was a
Catholic and there would not give him
communion was the issue that oh it's not
giving communion not given community
that's right of those extra
excommunicating no no no not all okay be
denied communion as I communique well
what that means in Catholicism I have no
idea how important it is but it must be
important to some Catholics yes and so
there was going to be a public meeting
on this and then the archbishop promised
to do it many reneged on it and I guess
this was probably shortly before the
election would be my guess this also
happened in 2004 there was a photo op
with bush in the Pope and all of a
sudden Democratic Party politicians only
were being criticized for not sir what's
that lasted so the question is why she
should be pointed to certainly positives
coming
do you agree that this is a good that
the Pope should have the right to do
this in any say other in maybe European
country and should the hierarchy follow
our follows instructions in his wife
okay thank you would like to speak for
the First Amendment right to the
Catholic Church well I've done a lot of
ocean suite then I I'm the next priest
so I think I can I can weigh in on it in
fact for Roman Catholics the Pope can
say whatever the heck you want and
people will do what they think is right
according to their conscience that's a
fundamental principle in Roman
Catholicism they have tried to play this
political game with abortion rights with
gay rights with gay marriage it is part
of this constant back and forth with in
American society where religious
institutions try to have an impact on
the structures of the state universally
every religious community tries
sometimes they win a bit more often they
lose okay yes absolutely can't good I
mean the principal at the religions can
do this is as relevant for liberal
causes like civil rights and so on where
churches were extremely important in
promoting that and for anti slavery and
so on so yes the Pope should have a
right to do this and as much as we might
not like it not being at the Catholic
religion that's it that's the right yes
sir andrew cousin Jerome is student at
Columbia and see on spoke speak up oh
sorry thank you yeah Andrew Kissinger
student at Columbia and she owns bow
graduate student I it seems to me one of
the bigger free speech issues what was
the Muhammad cartoons in Denmark which
were then republished throughout Europe
and as we know caused violent reaction
and surprisingly has resurfaced recently
with the editor being targeted again
violently and I guess newspapers pre
publishing them once again so it seems
to be recurrent issue
unfortunately um I was interested in how
the United States decided not to publish
the cartoons what your thoughts were as
to why the major newspapers and journals
did not publish it and if there are any
lessons learned any societal differences
that could be applied in that case I
should answer it yeah we publish what we
publish and you know to republish other
things as acts of solidarity seems
gratuitous we spoke forthrightly for the
right to do this now and the dangers and
the attacks on them have been disgusting
in my view it's as simple as that but
yet you chose not to publish it was
there any reason we publish it what we
publish in other words we publish the
work that we are generating we don't
Xerox from other other place we defended
their right to do it we support them
I've met with the editor I've been
public about my support about it's
really but that's were there American
publications that let's say it hadn't
been a religious thing it would be very
interesting internationally they would
have published I i have to say i don't
think that i can be accused of not look
at last summer last summer I have a very
liberal I think fairly liberal
readership and we published a cover in
which yes yeah you here for a First
Amendment in spirit we published a cover
in the teeth of ACTA called accusations
but notions and rumors and preposterous
biol thrown at the Obamas that they were
radicals that they were that Michelle
Obama was some kind of Angela Davis and
Barack Obama was a Muslim as if this
were innately a bad thing a terrorist
was unpatriotic and so Barry blit our
artist did something that really aroused
the ire of you know thousands of our
readers including the Obamas although I
I think their reaction was a bit
politically measured but there it was
and we received thousands of letters
some threats and we live to go on I in
other words i'm not there as a Xerox
machine for somebody else's cartoons if
we're going to provoke we're going to
provoke by generating our own work and
you know I and I have to say it was
deeply unpleasant I nowhere near what
was encountered there but if you're
going to publish a magazine it should be
provocative and provocative in the way
that you want it to be anyone else yes
about the cartoons I hear what you say
but it is not it is not only a question
of surak's it is a question of
solidarity when your friend and my
friend salmon orgy was condemned to
death for having integrated in one of
his novels three sentences which were
felt as a insult to dignity of Islam you
had in France a reflex of solidarity of
all publishers he was published by one
publisher like a random house or not for
whatever was Christian bajwa when he was
condemned all French publisher I know
the story because I took the initiative
of that at this time 10 or 12 French
publisher associated themselves to the
publisher they xeroxed the way a book in
a way the book from this time and for
the following month and years was
published by 8 10 12 I don't know
palacios so not xerox solidarity when
you are in a part of such as
such an effect because in the affair of
the cartoons that's why the question of
the young man is interesting it was a
self-inflicted blasphemy the affair of
the cattle because if you think of the
stories thoroughly the cartoons were
published in the newspaper
jyllands-posten syrup which us for
myself I never heard about I never heard
it highlighted shiny magazine tiny
magazine she's not true you knew it so
well even despite my food and then we
can imagine what the people of
mazar-e-sharif in Afghanistan of demoss
in Syria of isfahan in Iran if they
heard about Dylan post and so what
happened you had some activists
political activists not a religious
thinkers not religious worship else but
political activists who took the gene
and person who put them under the nose
of the worshippers who designated them
and who really in the blasphemy was not
inflicted by resident person but while
the burn was put in the brains by these
political I said why did they do that I
understand but I think you have the
story at least a little bit wrong is
that they had no idea when they publish
this that this would causes I know this
directly from the adverse like they
could not have an airhead no it was done
rather not blithely but with absolutely
no and this always happens when you get
a gigantic reaction you actually it's
the things that you don't anticipate the
closet I know but what exactly but what
I'm telling you is that gon person did
something without anticipating then
there was a declaration of war launched
by some people in Syria in Hamas or
wherever who decided to put fire fire in
embassies by the fire some Christian
priests I don't know where and so on war
being declared
by those guys I think that we had the
duty you did it in will occur in France
very few did it shall I abdo a very tiny
newspaper did it we had to manifest in
this war which didn't post and did not
declare that was declared by the self
inflicting blaspheme at all I'm thinking
about we had to show our solidarity why
did we were with so few to do it that is
the question and were so few newspapers
manifested the Solidarity because of
fear we were afraid in front of this
huge fire which was launched by these
few people spreading Zealand bastard who
never in history has such a glory in
front of that we were afraid I can tell
about my country very respectable
newspapers who would not have dared at
any price to reproduce to the rocks auto
by the fest their solidarity so always
the same in front of extremism of
fanaticism of fascism Democrats have all
possible virtuals merits except
sometimes and generally courage and
thank you
i just took to add to open up i don't
think that you're you're absolutely
right you're absolutely and I think you
know if our expression of doing this by
by dint of writing about it as opposed
to putting the cartoons with somehow
insufficient that I plead guilty but it
was not out of any sense of immediate
fear was just this happened we wrote
about it immediately and expressed
solidarity with them and it had met
publicly with the editor and all the
rest you know it I don't know where
where was these cartoons were
republished in the United States I
really go I have no idea no it no I
don't think so no Anna just as a matter
of fact to complete what you said even
the different governments I mean that
Danish products were boycotted by many
Arab countries and European countries
didn't do anything or on the United
States in solidarity yeah hi I'm Abby
Pogrebin I'm a writer for mr. Schmidt
you had mentioned that there was this
bullying event which kind of gathered
steam and there was a frontline a PBS
documentary called growing up online
that documented many cases of kids being
tormented very privately at first but
again snowballs to the point where some
commit suicide and it since we're in a
university I'm wondering what you think
is appropriate and possible because we
do live in America where we leave value
for your speech but clearly when their
kids or students is there a different
standard and should there be and for
anyone else who wants to address it I
mean first of all it is very important
to have awareness of a problem and
awareness for the parents the professor
of the community and it's regarding and
it's complicated because yes it's behind
the computer and I remember a twist
conference there was the director of the
of a school saying okay you know when
the kids were fighting the inverse
cruelly you can see them you can see the
blood but we have a computer you cannot
see it so it's very complicated and you
need awareness awareness and and food
awareness I think we got in cyber
building that's the main thing to be a
very very present with the kids but
you're saying awareness you're not
saying restrictions I mean it if the
kids under 18 the pants you know you've
got many software now that can help and
it's it's obvious that unity use when
but restriction in again you need to be
in a position to do it because how are
you going to restrict what word are you
going to take out it's very complicated
we anyway we will not have a pure
internet but not what we want but it
would not be possible to we are not
looking for one hundred percent solution
we are looking for at least two to go
forward unto fifty sixty seventy eighty
percent my name is her seat at I'm
chemist that I'm actually an alumnus of
Columbia I want to bring up again the
very troubling question about whether
one should legislate about the denial of
the Holocaust and my problem is that you
didn't want to legislate against
stupidity because the overwhelming
evidence is so strong and so on but that
doesn't protect future generations I
mean if you keep on going with
generations and generations and putting
and denying the Holocaust freely then in
another two or three generations history
gets rewritten and forgotten for example
I me bring up another very controversial
little point today people don't realize
that between the from the 18th century
onward until the end of the British
Mandate the majority of the population
of Jerusalem proper was Jewish the Arab
villages were around the answer what is
your question that my question is what
do you do about shouldn't there be
legislation to protect future
generations guess what we're going to do
we're going to take a few questions at a
time and then and the panelists will
address with the can we have a number of
questions limited time we're now it
wants to give and should give a closing
statement so sir and we're not ignoring
your question I promise we're not
ignoring it my name is David Masada the
question is for Bernard today with the
massive migration of the
muslim population into europe and the
fact that you just talked about this
cartoon that got you afraid and most of
europe today under toes how is europe
dealing with the fact that you have the
muslim population factor to deal with
and most of the political pandering
today is very sensitive about how am I
going to get their vote but in the
meantime they are changing the entire
fabric of the Western society in Europe
okay and one and one more and then and
then we'll start with Bernard yes sir
thank you hi I'm Ben I'm a law student
here at Columbia and I guess my question
is for the panel I took a First
Amendment class last semester without
professor blah see a First Amendment
specialist at the law school and I wrote
a paper on Hill vs colorado which is a
Supreme Court case where the supreme
court upheld the statute which basically
restricted created a bubble around
people entering health care facilities
essentially this was enacted to protect
people trying to get abortions and I
guess my question would be where do you
guys stand on sort of a proportional
response to you know sort of tension
between the free speech of the sort of
activists that are trying to get out
this message and the women trying to
receive abortions or would you prefer
more of absolute worst Angus that okay
so I think what we'll do is Ken my guess
is that's a question for you internet
question for you and and the two
gentleman over here I swear I'll get to
you I if you stay there I'll get to you
and then the question that went to you
and Bernard I think you two can
certainly share that so grenard you want
to start you forgot who stopped what
which question I thought I was doing
this so masterfully and yet it slipped
through my hands about which question
Martin denial of holocaust denial
focused I told you the only serious
reason the true reason to to to make a
penalty on denial of a no cost is that
it is part of the crime it is not denial
of the crime denial of Holocaust is not
denial of the crime it is continuation
of the crime it is part of the crime the
project of Holocaust included the denial
this is the reason why denial should be
finished not only for lower costs but
also for armenian genocide and on super
order today in France you have I'm sorry
for my country it's like this we have a
school of so-called thought which is
already engaged thoroughly with an
incredible energy in denying the
Holocaust in order already a few years
after and you have a lot of political
issues in France who are or political
disputes between our minister of foreign
affairs for example and some people and
so on which are unexplainable without
this landscape of the denial of the
genocide of water it is a sickness of
the mind when you have genocide you have
denial while because there is part of
the crime this is a depth of the
question more important than stupidity
hand bad currency and so on and so on
this is a deep reply to a deep and
vertiginous question can't I think you
should answer the young hasta just it's
just in general I think one thing is
what message you can say and then
another question is at what point can
you deliver it to certain people and
I do think that that particular
restriction there didn't make sense but
that's certainly that they could say
they're messing someplace else so freely
you think that you have no no no okay so
I again we can't get to everything we're
doing the best we can and you'll have
these three and ask them boom boom boom
and and we'll have them answered and
then and then Bernard will speak sir yes
my name is dr. Robert April and the
question is very simple well what do you
think about this kind of negative
cartoon going on in America about the
Fort Hood massacre I think a wonderful
new yorker cartoon might be the
questioning of dr. hassan and a caption
what is it why is there no real media
reporting of the nature of this act a
missing year I don't know what it's
necessarily the seems to me is that we
are so afraid of blasphemy in our First
Amendment country that the press doesn't
talk about things that seem to be real
the you major I'm talking about the
murder at Fort Hood by the staff
psychiatrist in the United States Army
who I understand that but we have had no
media reporting oh the umbilical a wave
of the investigation subsequently and I
wonder if that's not a negative
suggesting that they said there's a
negative cartoon in this a negative
cartoon in a sense that we're covering
one up we don't want to cheek about the
reality of this terrorist attack in
those terms and take the necessary steps
at least not publicly because of our
fear of and those necessary steps are
well I don't want to talk about those
but i find it funny because i'm not sure
what they are because i don't know the
fact but you see i'm saying that this is
a kind of fear of expressing feelings
that might injure a feelings of a
certain can I wish I could accept your
premise but I die just yet can I can I
say a word about this myth would it be
might be wrong about this but would it
be fear that we're not if people are not
sure
what the actual motivation was and I
think if that's right it may be correct
that they're hesitant to say it
contributed to something that would be
sort of a deeply condemning of some
group unless they're really sure about
it I don't think it necessarily is
condemning to get to explore and report
okay yes hi my name is Renee Morris and
I am a journalist and I'm my question
has to do with with regard to the laws
that we were disgusting that were
present on the panel is it a possibility
that there could be a universal
community not the United Nations
obviously that could set some standards
as to what is sort of searched in stone
and that becomes a law in itself it
becomes something that you can look
towards as to define what you what you
think might be an answer to these
questions for example on Rwanda or the
Holocaust they could be the quote
authority as to someone kind of super
disagree that supranational Los Angeles
Suzanne you want supra national laws
even super neck well damn it it would
have to be an agreement of story I've
done to do what to Teddy story no I'm
simply saying dragula not to regulate
but to have an opinion that is written
that this occurred this occurred this
occurred and they will always be the
naysayers like we have Galileo or
whatever and then people came up and
said no the earth isn't round I mean I
know people who don't think we landed on
okay I think we have that question and
then we'll have yours in that will try
to visit is the possible kidding fair
enough yes ma'am my name is Marsha de
sanctis and this is a question for
professor Greenwald is there ever a time
or at what point was something that's
very very left wing or very very right
wing right wing in this administration
left wing perhaps in the last is there
ever a line this cross that is actually
considered treasonous where something
was so strong that it would actually be
considered treason to criticize or two
or to suggest some kind of action
against the government or or perhaps
wish for a president's failure or
something along those lines specially go
ahead yeah sure okay so and my
understanding is the requirements of
treason are actually extremely limited
so I think that that this you actually
have to be offering aid to an enemy a
real enemy and more time the the closest
thing I can it comes to mind though is
that the rules about the Communist Party
that existed in 1950s were with really
violence if there was going to be a one
was way down the road where there were
some criminal convictions and
suppression I think it's striking though
that during the Vietnam War which was
highly controversial that that opinions
were expressed and that I as far as I
know nobody got prosecuted for
statements about that quite contrary to
what happened during the First World War
so okay does anybody want to enjoy that
question regarding the previous question
yes yes yeah I think I mean in fact your
question is interesting because it's
redeem eight we have regarding when you
have a memo is no I mean whoever denial
of Rio locos laws or I mean the
government is not hear of one specific
country of all the government of the
world to write his toy that's that's not
a good solution that cannot be a good
solution
I'd like to thank everybody on the panel
I'd like to thank you we are not done
don't reach for your coats don't reach
for your guns it's a great privilege to
introduce Bernard honry Levy who is
really one of the most forthright and
one of the bravest spokesman for freedom
of speech here or anywhere and he will
close this with a few minutes of closing
statement Bernard
it's difficult to close because all that
was said was really interesting and not
an interesting paying tribute to the
complexity of the debate it's really one
of the most complex and difficult debate
this question of freedom of speech one
point on which I think we all agreed
that speech is not a neutral vehicle
speech is not just words words words
there is a wait there is consistency
there is a huge force of the worlds
which cannot be treated just like this
wealth is not only a vehicle of thought
it has a false as such this is the point
i think our discussion about denial of
holocaust about internet and all that on
which we could agree victory go said yo
mu 0 ver believe a lucid you illumise
you verbally obsidia Milania quoted at
the beginning I think we are all agree
on the fact that both of them and many
others are right when they insist of
this incredible fire which is inside and
beneath the words we are not just
playing with a neutral surface of things
when we speaks about speech and about
worlds we are really speaking about the
burning core of the things and of the
human condition this Israel these non
neutral worlds which we call speech
therefore I think we agree again on that
all of us they can have a two-fold
vocation but to fold the wall they can
kill and they can save they can kill and
they can save if you listen for example
to
french writer I'm sorry but I know a
little better of whom it is a lot
question these days who is alberca me
Albert Camus said that huge modern
crimes large-scale crimes of the 20th
century could never have been committed
without the legitimation the
acceleration of the world's he said that
there were crimes of worlds crimes
without words crimes without speech
would have been really infinitely less
serious and grave and and and harmful so
once according to Albert Camus can be
that this acceleration of Christ and
world's can be the contrary they can
save they can save our brothers in Iran
know that they know that it is an
addition of speeches freedom of words
which can save them from tyranny and
they are fighting for free speech before
anything else in a way I welcome in my
friend journal arregle usual in its
website I devoted special space to the
voices of the resistance in Iran the
youngsters the women human rights
militants they all of them say that the
core of our fight is production
circulation of worlds battle for free
speech the same could be said and you
know that in America better than
anywhere Google the same could be said
about China the battle in China the
battle against this strange monster
which is a jungle capitalism mixed with
the most ironic communism which is a
regime in China the the only possible
resistance to that is the freedom of
speech and the dissidents in China other
dissidents in Soviet Union 20 years ago
they fight for freedom of speech in my
youth in the 70s in the 80s when we
began to fill the Soviet empire being
for fragile easy what was the real
weapon what was a real tool if not the
freedom of speech that makes our
discussion about internet at the same
time serious and not so serious internet
of course has to be moderated of course
internet is the theater and the space
and the place of the worst but at the
time of the fight for democracy in China
at the moment where happens when the
Democratic wave in Iran expresses itself
through Facebook and Twitter and
Internet I think the real battle is not
the battle for the constraints for the
moderation for laws on internet but
freedom of infant internet and my deep
feeling is that Internet can be the
worst can also be the best thing in the
world and my feeling is that the time
will come when internet will find its
all its own ways of regulations there in
internet the bad currency will be get
rid of by the good one maybe you will
even see a peer maybe one
David Remnick will take the initiative
with some people in the web of a sort of
moral authority giving a sort of level a
label to negative or a positive label on
the websites existing today those who
spread stupid rumors those who who build
a real information we might see things
like that I really believe that this
world of internet will find with our
help maybe its ways of regulations and
the debate for me is not the debate of
today my real belief is that the
emergency is to help the Chinese
decisions to have access free access at
Google and to help the information in
Iran to go out through facebook and
through Twitter this is a democratic
battle now if I try to sum up as
faithfully as possible our our debates
the question which which have been
raised I cannot I cannot avoid the
evidence that a lot of our discussions
turned around the question of Islam
Muslim communities in Europe totally
terrorism in Arab countries and so odd
about this I would like not only to
summer but maybe to make a step forward
to clarify a few things if you allow me
if you allow me about the Muslim
presents the big Muslim community in
France and in Europe I would make I
would like to make one point very clear
it is true that in France for example in
England in Germany there is a a big
Muslim community what is not true is
that this come
nity should be considered as a threat as
itself as a threat to democracy this is
not true and not even as a threat
against judaism more Jews and so on that
is not true the reality in France I'm
sure elsewhere in Europe is my feeling
is that this big Muslim community is
crossed by is divided by a line real
front line dividing two camps putting
the stage for a real battle a real
civilization battle inside Islam between
democratic forces and between
fundamentalist and fascist forces you
have to the entrance a real fight a
political one between fascism and
democracy inside ISA my feeling is that
the fascist forces inside the Muslim
community in France they shout very very
much you hear them a lot as always the
extremists express themselves always
much more strongly than the moderate
this is low but I don't believe that the
other majority I do believe that they
are today it may change tomorrow but at
the moment when we speak in France in
England in Germany my strong belief is
that the huge the biggest majority of
this community has one aspiration which
is to follow the path of previous
minorities having integrated themselves
in the past in the French Republican
modelo and to adopt the values of
democracy and republic but it does not
mean that the battle is not going on it
does not mean that you don't have some
people some civilian activists some
uncivil yanez activists people in the
middle like Tariq Ramadan I know Thank
good for you I know that telecom Otto
has recuperated his visa to go to
America your problem i think that Tariq
Ramadan does not belong to this
Democratic wing of the Muslim community
but that is another question so there is
a battle going on where this battle for
the moment has not been one and far from
it by the extremist forces now if you
try to look inside this battle what are
the stakes in this Muslim world inside
Europe inside America at the end of the
day you are the Muslims of America you
have in the catskills this Muslim
community which was linked to the murder
of Daniel Pearl i found that in my book
but the nepal it is not only europe you
have also a program in America too it's
like anti-semitism it is not a European
speciality so what is going on in Islam
in Europe in America and in the Arab and
non-arab Islamic world there is a
question of religion and there is a
question of politics the question of
religion the religious debate is not for
me the most important but it exists it
is a debate between those and I I
rebound of something which has been said
in the beginning it is a discussion
between those who inside Islam think
that they are the only one that there is
only one
faith only one way to embrace the faith
which is well and those who believe that
there is a lot of roads a lot of paths
this is the real point Christianity made
a huge step forward a huge progress
Christianity Catholicism in particular
at the time of Vatican the circles in
Vatican the second one very simple thing
has been said regarding the Jews before
Vatican to the Jews were considered as
the fathers of the Christians the very
respected river of the fathers but the
fathers their book the holy book was
considered as a testament the Old
Testament the vocation of a father is to
die and to be replaced by the Sun and
the vocation of an Old Testament is to
disappear to be replaced by the good one
by the new one Vatican to change
completely the point of view by saying
that Jews and Christian when a father
and son but were brothers elder brother
younger brother this was Vatican 2 and
this was really an earthquake inside
Catholicism when it was said that it was
not a relationship of fatherhood but of
brotherhood then it was said that I was
two possible roads toward the truth
there was two possible ways to embrace
it and not only one which was scheduled
to replace the other inside the Judaism
the same thing happened with emmanuel
levinas and before emmanuel levinas with
France whoresons Vega a hose and vague a
very important Jewish german-jewish
thinker or the beginning of the 20th
century who said also this very simple
thing which changed all the lands
there is to access to ways of access to
the being the being in the in the
meaning of Aristotle the being there is
not were only one way but two possible
way the Christian Way and the Jewish way
when this was said by Hassan's vague
Inlet Waldo Luray doms you and by
emmanuel levinas seen many of his books
it was real it was the stone the the
founding stone of the impossibility of
fanaticism and of extremism into Judaism
there can always be as everywhere some
people who say that to discuss with the
Arabs and so on these are public of
course but the main stream of Judaism
has changed with thousands vague and
leaving us because giving the
possibility to the truth to be said in
two different languages today the
mainstream is in Islam the mainstream
consists in saying that there was one
false revelation God speaking to Moses
one second opposed to you fakeness hoax
second Hawks which was God speaking to
the Christ hoax one hopes to and that at
the end of the day came the only single
unique direct speaking from God God to
somebody who was God speaking to moment
so this idea of to revelations being
just fakes hoax volume how do some
volume drafts bad drafts and then the
world itself this means that the Islamic
world has not yet made the work which
has been
by Christianity and by Judaism the other
things which the other religions have
done and which Islam has still to do and
will do i'm sure is to consider that
this given world this given world has
been given but in spite of having been
given by god maybe commented discussed
put into debate between human beings
each time a religion committed this act
of saying that a given world can be
subjected to human discussion it was a
revolution it was a revolution in the in
the whole world when the jews for
example invented the talmud the talmud
which is the very core of judaism much
more than the Bible levena said that the
Jewish people is not the people daughter
of the Torah he said he he went to the
point to say that it was the people of
the Talmud why because the Talmud is
this place where the world of God is
indefinitely discussed Islam will and
definitely and forever in in a ground
where fanaticism will be impossible will
be completely excluded when it will
adopt invent produce some sort of it
will not be the same of course but
something looking like like laws of the
fathers of the church all the Talmud of
the rabbi's in Judaism you have to do
some scholars in the Muslim world who
believe that who believe that the
solution that they exit from the
fanaticism either in the possibility in
the right in the intellectual tools
allowing to put two to consider that the
given world is subject to discuss
has a meaning which is not closed is
like the wings of the Spirit which has
which are folding and which have to be
unfolded and so on this is a religious
question when in the Islamic world you
will have number one the idea that there
is two three four roads to the truth and
when you will have the idea that the
given word is an open letter an open
letter like open letter to the president
ba ba ba publish news but an open letter
not only a little and open data when you
will have these two things all that
belongs to religion in this question of
freedom of speech inside Islam will be
on the process of resolution now you
have in the Islamic world another
problem with cheese politic my neighbor
of panel said that you had some
countries in Arab world which were which
are totalitarian yes and no yes and no i
did not say totally i wouldn't i did not
that i would not say totalitarian if we
think about if we think of the same
countries or political movements they
are not totalitarian if we were if we
want to be accurate we have to say that
they are the queue of an old comment the
end of an old black staff which was a
black star the horrible star of the
fascism of the thirties this is a thing
which has been said here by my friend
Paul Berman in a book published 10 years
ago and which I try to develop myself in
some further in some posterior works the
Arabic world was absent absolutely not
out of the fascist revolution it was
involved in
there was a an Arabic version of it ruga
mufti of jerusalem but many other bus
party and so on and so on and the point
is that the Arabic world and the Muslim
world is the only one to which the
question of its pacifist past has not
been addressed as long at it will as it
will not be addressed as long as public
opinions the leaders the Mubarak's the
people of Syria's Assad the Ayatollah
advising Ahmadinejad Ayatollah yes d for
example very important person in Iran
today who is a true fascist ended in the
meaning in the way of the 30s as long as
this question will not be raised clearly
which is not in religious terms but in
political terms we shall be completely
blind in what happens in this world you
said that Israel is a catalyst of that I
don't think so Israelis not even a
catalyst without Israel it will be
exactly the same it would be exactly the
same I had a few years ago very strong
experience I spent I spent a part of my
time during when you're in Pakistan by
in Pakistan they don't even know of dr.
leaders of God but the population has a
very slight idea of what Israel is the
Palestinian case they don't give a damn
for that Palestinian in Pakistan has a
name which is Kashmir they care about
Kashmir so in this country where you
care about Kashmir where you never saw a
Palestinian while you have no jewels
nevertheless you have this very strange
anti-zionism without the ilysm
anti-semitism without are Jews and so on
and so on so Israel is not
question without the existence of Israel
it would be exactly the same scheme it
will be exactly the same pattern the
pattern will exist will or without it
because it is an old story Hamas and
Hezbollah for example my problem is not
again with Islam there my problem is
with fascism Hamas and Hezbollah the
real problem is that they have their
feet they have their roots they have
their legs still here in the in the mud
in the muddy water of an old fascism
which has not been yet dragged in this
area of the world and to finish not the
question of Israel not totally tourism
but fascism and about somebody spoke
about the buca's and the veil and scarf
as a dress code it is not a dress code
it is a political code it is a political
message and if we as long as we consider
I don't say that we have to forbid or
not probably there is a big debate in
France has to be in forbidden or not in
the public space or beyond the privacy
this is a political question but did
question is to admit that the burka
which has nothing to do with worshipping
as you know which has nothing to do with
Quran all the current specialists know
that the bearing of boca is nowhere in
Quran recommended and pray and ordered
it is not a religious topic it is a
political message and the political
message who says what who says a very
simple thing I think against which all
Democrats in America add in Europe and
in Muslim world fight and fight and
fight since ages the message of the
vodka and of the scarf is that there is
a sort of native an equality between men
and women the political message of buca
is that the men have a face and the
women the face of a women is not a face
is a scandal this is a political message
the inequality between women and men
consists in the fact that the face of
the woman is an arranged entire which
has to be mastered which has to be
hidden which has to be neutralized this
idea that the face of the women and the
body has to be neutralized because it is
an ashram provocative because it is a
provocative agent be too because it is a
seed of disorder because it is a way of
destroying humanity because it is an
ontological impurity this has nothing to
do with Islam thanks God this has to do
with an old tradition with his
transition version a variant of fascism
so to finish with that to finish with
the whole thing because it's my role I'm
sorry the debate about freedom of speech
or not denial of a low cost and all the
question we have raised since two hours
is not an academic debate is not a
religious debate it is the all brave all
debate which we know well we had to face
it you Americans as Europeans and we
defeated him we defeated the bad part of
the debate and we will defeat it again
in the new situation it is a debate
between democracy and fascism this is
the question of today in Iran in China
in some parts of the Muslim world and
this is
the battle we have to wait and to win
wind in particular the freedom of speech
Thank
thank you
thank you very much for your concluding
remarks please join me in thanking our
guest tonight for a great panel thank
you again to the liqua for their
collaboration and thank you all for
coming we look forward to welcoming you
at Columbia again thank you all